good afternoon everyone gives me great
pleasure to welcome all of you to a
special keynote lecture that we have
organized today that serves multiple
purposes first of all as you know this
year we slightly changed the format of
our Martin Luther King Day celebrations
rather than having an event that that
focuses on one day we thought for a
variety of reasons based on input from
most many of you around campus that we
will preserve the best practices of the
past but at the same time spread it over
a period of a few weeks so that we not
only have an opportunity to celebrate
the single day of the year which is a
national holiday but also more
importantly the message behind the day
itself through a series of activities so
we had the poetry competition for
students not just from here but around
around town we have a important lecture
today and other activities on campus so
one of the purposes of today's keynote
event is to as part of our weeks long or
month-long celebration of the legacy of
dr. Martin Luther King jr. to have this
keynote lecture the other purpose is
because of the particularly individual
we were able to attract as a speaker
today we thought it will be extremely
appropriate to have combined it at the
same time with the Simon initiative
Distinguished Lecture and as a result
today's event is both Martin Luther King
Day celebration and Simon initiative
Distinguished Lecture as you know access
to higher education is a requirement for
career in almost any field today in the
global economy and it doesn't matter
whether you are a stem science
technology and
and mathematics major or a citizen who
pursues any other profession or you are
just a person who doesn't have any other
profession as a global citizen the 21st
century you have no choice but to
intersect with technology whether you
like it or not and the 21st century is
going to be a century that defines that
intersection between technology and the
human condition but more so than any
other century and one of the things we
are very fortunate about at Carnegie
Mellon is our excellence in at that
intersection of Technology and human
condition and that's gonna mean that we
have at least a critical mass of
citizens in every country and I'm
talking here in particular with about
the us who are technologically and
scientifically savvy but who also have
an appreciation for the bigger picture
and the human condition unfortunately
for too many young people especially
from America's disadvantaged communities
especially people of color college still
remains out of reach so if you can't
pass algebra in high school you are not
going to college
it's not going to be that easy equally
if you look around the country more and
more young girls aged 17 and 18 excel in
high school I don't know what the
numbers are today at least a few years
ago I used to know these numbers by
heart as of that date more than 70% of
the valedictorians in American high
schools both public and private we're
girls and that fraction is increasing
and yet a large fraction of them don't
enter these STEM fields
because of a variety of highly complex
set of factors and those play into the
stem pipeline for the country so
graduating
from high school with realistic
expectation of continuing one's
education is not the norm for many who
come from underprivileged backgrounds
dr. King's vision of equal social
opportunity for all is thus profoundly
linked to the goals of many things we do
it's a national need and equally it's
one of the things that we aspire to
achieve through initiatives such as the
Simon initiative at Carnegie Mellon
where you have access to information
access to technology that amplifies your
outcome for learning no matter where you
reside and no matter how underprivileged
a background you may come from our guest
today has devoted his life to making dr.
King's vision a reality in higher
education my good friend dr. Freeman
hrabowski has for the past 22 years
served as president of the University of
Maryland Baltimore County which is a
public university campus in an
impoverished inner city his students are
I wanna scampers with wide variations in
how ready they are for university
studies especially in areas such as math
and science yet UMBC today graduates
more african-american students who go on
to achieve PhDs in STEM fields or joint
MD PhDs than any other University in the
US Freeman and his staff have
accomplished this with a multi-faceted
approach that has great implications for
the design of higher education not just
for minority students but for all
Freeman has a number of distinguished
honors to his credit I won't mention all
of them you can find them online I'll
just mention a few he's been nationally
recognized for many of his remarkable
achievements especially in impacting
higher education
for underrepresented students under the
president minority students he has
received the academic Leadership Award
from the Carnegie Corporation of New
York in 2012 he received a Heinz award
from CMU trustee mrs. Teresa Heinz and
the Heinz Family Foundation President
Obama named him to chair the president's
Advisory Commission on educational
excellence for african-americans
I had the personal opportunity and
pleasure of knowing Freeman while I was
director of the National Science
Foundation he visited me on a number of
occasions at NSF and I also had the
opportunity to visit him and be a
commencement speaker in 2012 for the
undergraduate class of University of
Maryland Baltimore County and I have I
have to say I have I'm also he claims an
alumnus of UMBC I have an unearned and
undeserved degree from his he was an
inspiring advisor to many of the
programs that that we offer at the
National Science Foundation especially
especially targeted for underrepresented
groups I was telling our student group
at lunch today that the National Science
Foundation spends about a billion
dollars a year on targeted stem programs
for underrepresented groups in the
country that's about one third of what
the entire federal government spends on
targeted stem programs so please join me
in welcoming dr. Freeman hrabowski to
Carnegie Mellon to speak about dr.
King's dream and the American University
today
thank you very very much sudra I really
appreciate that I'm delighted to be here
I am I am taking this as my opportunity
to forgive Carnegie Mellon University
because for years I have always said
that this institution wonderful as it is
stole my math chair Jim Greenberg to be
the bath chair here and as hot a man as
Jim Greenberg was we loved him all right
and and we've always been very proud
that he moved from UMBC to Carnegie
Mellon and we've taken great pleasure in
seeing students come here and have very
good experiences I was delighted to have
one of them at lunch today not a who is
a PhD student in mechanical engineering
but we have a number of your graduates
who are on the faculty at my institution
and I wanted to to read to you and add
in the most recent issue of the Museum
of mathematics of the National Museum of
mathematics to says come see the New
York premiere of a provocative new play
explaining how and whether mathematics
can inspire or be inspired by the arts
and humanities watch the fireworks fly
as fractals interact with Shakespeare
and it is to be performed in March March
8th at the National Museum of
mathematics in in New York and that same
flavors actually produced this week at
the joint mathematics meeting in Houston
and there's an incredible blog about it
if you get a chance look at the blog
well the reason I bring it up is that
the two people who wrote the production
are UMBC graduates Menil Surrey in
mathematics and Michelle Asher Oh in
literature Michele is works also with
the Folgers and Museum in Washington and
Manila a fascinating mathematician has
actually had three bestselling novels in
the past ten years the age of Vishnu the
death of Vishnu the age of Shiva and the
City of David
they're both Carnegie Mellon graduates
and they take great pride and
I mentioned this to colleagues last
night they were saying that's the kind
of thing we do the idea of
interdisciplinary however it's not often
that you hear about the mathematics of
being human and the the the production
comes as a result of their very
difficult conversations some years ago
to produce a Freshman Seminar for
students in the humanities and in the
STEM disciplines way you bring students
together to talk about
cross-disciplinary and interestingly
enough that seminar went so well that
there is a three part series that was in
The Chronicle of Higher Education we got
a lot of people coming to look at it and
finally that went so well that they did
this place so if you get a chance look
at the vlog and it may intrigue you and
you may want to invite them here since
we can both claim them UMBC and Carnegie
Mellon but we have a lot of people from
your campus who are now on our campus
from the arts in imaging and digital
arts all the way over to mathematics and
computer science I began with poetry
William Carlos Williams once said that
it's difficult to find news in poetry
and yet men die miserably every day
because of a lack of what is found there
it was our beloved and late now Maya
Angelou who said to this country more
than 20 years ago at a presidential
inauguration lift up your eyes upon this
day breaking for you give birth again to
the dream women children men take it
this dream into the palms of your hands
mold it into the image of your most
private self sculpted into the shape of
your most public need here on the pulse
of this new day you may have the grace
to look up and out and into your sisters
eyes and into your brother's face and
say simply very simply with hope good
morning good afternoon to Carnegie
Mellon good afternoon give Maya Angelou
a hand for poetry would you please
if I made the mistake of shaking your
hand please wash your hands I have the
flu all right and I don't want to give
you as a gift it's kind of your melon
the flu so please don't breathe towards
me so you don't get my my condition I I
I want to tell a story you know my
campus is an interesting place with
students from 150 countries and so we
talk about both domestic and
international diversity it is a place
where the life of the mind is very
active I like telling people my
basketball team reads really well they
don't want a lot of games would they
read really well and we we are usually
in the Final Four in chess when you see
a chess play on my campus you bow in
reverence you really do all of the 18
members are grandmasters quite frankly
and the Maryland chess champion is on
the C team so it's a really hot place
with chess but but it is Baltimore and
Baltimore is what I call the upper south
the upper south the emphasis on upper
all right one day we think like people
in Philadelphia the next day like people
in Richmond it depends on the issue now
we would call you the North Pittsburgh
all right but I grew up in the deep
south and a place that was called quite
frankly the Pittsburgh of the South
Birmingham Alabama because of the steel
industry and in the deep south we tell
stories now how many of you are old
enough to have seen the movie by dog
with it with Dolly Parton's of Steel
Magnolias right you know at some point
in the middle of the movie somebody is
in the beauty parlor and they're telling
a big lie all the cosmetologist are
looking at each other yeah right and the
person leaves and Dolly says there's a
story there well the fact is that
everyone has a story each of us has a
story and our stories in many ways shape
our thinking about who we are and my
story is intertwined with that of the
civil rights movement and with dr. King
I was sitting in the back of a church in
the middle of a week and not wanting to
be there what kid wants to be in church
in the middle of the week and my parents
had brought me and being there with the
two things I love the most
eating and mathematics I was getting
smarter and fatter all the time and I
was eating some M&Ms that the count with
the peanuts the good guy right and doing
this math problem and I was 12 and all
of a sudden the man said and if the
children participate in this peaceful
protest all of America will understand
that even our babies know the difference
between right and wrong and want a
better education and I looked up because
my first thought was god I I'd be able
to get rid of these hand-me-down books
we were given the hand-me-down books
from white kids once they had used them
for years and years they put brown paper
bag on the paper on them to try to edit
me peel it back and you'd see it they
were raggedy books from white schools
and and when my parents wanted to buy my
own books they were told you can't do
that because then the kid will think
he's better than other children and so
if you can imagine the psychological
effect on children realize and they were
not considered good enough to get their
own books but could only get those that
were handed down from white children it
was an awful experience and this man was
saying to us perhaps this wouldn't have
to be the case perhaps kids could go to
the best schools we had some great black
teachers but we didn't have the
resources and I said who is that guy and
they said of course his name was dr.
Martin King and I got goosebumps because
he he was the first one to say to me
that the world of tomorrow could be
different in the world of today I was
talking to both subra and Farnam earlier
about innovation and about my own
background and what I will say to you is
that the challenge we face in America
particularly as we think about
innovation I would say an education and
the American University is to believe
ourselves and then help our students
believe that we can be empowered to make
the world better for people than it is
today that things don't have to remain
just as they
and so I I was fascinated and I said to
my parents we got home I've got a goal
I've got to go gotta go in March and
they said absolutely not and I looked at
them and I said you know you guys made
me go to this I didn't want to go you
told me to listen I did the man wants me
to go in March you tell me I can't
you're really hypocrites its students at
that time you did not tell your parents
name we hypocrites you did not do that
my dad said go to your room boy and it
was the next morning they came in it
prayed all night it was a terrible night
for them and and they said it wasn't
that we didn't trust you we did not
trust the people who would be over you
because if you go you will go to jail I
was 12 I was I was I'd skipped grades I
was about to go to the tenth grade so I
was ahead on my classes I was a little
more mature but here's the point I did
go
not because I was courageous the only
thing I'd ever fought in my life was a
math problem I could attack those math
problems right if it get time for a
fight students I was running the other
way you got that I had no problem
telling you I was a wimp all right I'm
fat little smart well okay but I did go
because I could talk people made me in
charge of a group of kids and we get up
to and I tell you students this because
it's what what when I wrote an article
in the last year or two about this for
the White House folks what was
surprising to me was to figure out the
percentage of Americans who were not in
the world in 1963 what's this how many
of you had not been born as of 1963
that's disgusting I want you to know
that the fact is that two-thirds of
Americans were not born at that time so
it would be impossible for you to
understand what the rest of us who were
in the world even if we were kids saw in
the world in 1963 in 1963 even in the
North you would never have a room
looking like this ever with the women or
people of color the world has changed
dramatically since that period but I did
go and terrible experience and was
thrown in jail thrown into a police
wagon by the chief of police Bull Connor
it was awfully spat on me and threw me
in just getting their own nigger it was
awful and spent a week and the
experience was empowering
it was hard but it taught me that even
children could make a difference in
their own lives and could be taught to
think critically now I have always tied
my solving math problems and thinking
about what this man was talking about
how do you deal with issues of poverty
and of segregation and of discrimination
I've always tied the idea of critical
thinking skills and math and science
together just as because I have a mother
who's an English teacher I learned the
appreciation of poetry and literature
and thinking skills and understanding
how to use language at that same period
my mother was who had been an English
teacher was going back to school for
something called the new math how many
of you knew grandma the new mad about
old enough forever the new math well the
one of the reasons the new math didn't
work and after I read it was so afraid
that Russia was gonna be better than
Americans and everything else was that
we and universities didn't really know
how to work effectively necessarily with
K to 12 because we tend to be rather
condescending in in the Academy if you
know what I mean
towards K through 12 and what we didn't
understand was that teachers know
children we know the content but we
don't know children and that effective
partnerships really do result when
people show respect for each side and
somehow Americans ended up being even
more frightened of math of set theory
my mother was was a smart woman and who
loved poetry but she was intrigued by
math went back and I was her guinea pig
and what she learned that has shaped my
thinking about producing students in
science in engineering is that we don't
discuss problems in stem using numbers
whether it's in engineering or in
medicine whatever the area we discuss
problems in words and we learn how to
look at the relationships among words
and from the relationships we come up
with symbols that we come up with
equations and we solve problems but
reading skills reading skills thinking
skills and reading skills are critical
to achievement in science and this is
what I was learning from her as she was
getting this connection between what she
had always said it in English and
becoming a math teacher at the same time
and I bring those two things together
because as we look at America right now
and as we look at what's happening in
higher education we have more students
going to college than ever and I'll talk
about that and not for a place like
Carnegie Mellon or UMBC but for American
higher education the number one area
where students are not succeeding and
therefore not even getting to the second
year work his developmental mathematics
the Carnegie Foundation at Stanford is
shown I mean it's so clear that large
percentages of students from
underrepresented groups and white kids
from the bottom third to almost 40%
cannot get past the belt on the math
which is middle school mathematics major
challenges that we face one of my
mother's favorite authors was or in
their Hurston who wrote a book in which
the beginning words a ships at a
distance have every man's wish on board
for some they come in with the tide for
others they sail forever on the horizon
never out of sight never landing until
the watcher turns his head away in
resignation his dreams mocked to death
by time that is the life of men and my
mother would say and women and the point
was two groups of people people like you
people whose dreams in many ways have
already some dreams fulfilled on your
way to fulfilling all those wonderful
stories and then people who were whose
dreams are in the words of Langston
Hughes forever deferred Hurston's point
my mother's point was this the
difference between those dreams being
fulfilled and dreams not being fulfilled
is often education where would anybody
in the room be if he or she had not
received the level of education that
you're getting right now now let me ask
a question you know that that children's
March was in the early sixties students
and then there was a march on Washington
and you see the movie now Selma all
period all those marches and they led to
legislation and and if you've read
master of the standard on any of the
books on Lyndon Johnson the man really
did play a powerful role in helping with
it's a powerful role that he's not given
credit for in that movie and he was a
good ol southern boy who used his
southern context and changed the
Senate's thinking and they were able to
pass the civil rights legislation and as
I said this last year too and and at a
School Board Association of school
boards in Georgia
and a very wealthy man who was head of
one of the school board said I want to
say something to the audience I had no
idea what he's gonna say he said you
know when we think about the civil
rights legislation we think about people
of color blacks maybe Hispanics now he
said and women he said when I you see me
I'm a rich white guy I'm CEO of my
company
I'm a head of the school board in my
city and you expect or you assume that I
come from well he said nothing could be
further from the truth he said I grew up
on a sharecropping family my father was
dead my mom I had to share crop we
didn't make any money we were very poor
we would call white trash she said but
we saw the little Negro children
starting to go to college in the
mid-1960s and my mama said I want my
children to go to college and we did we
got the little financial aid they had
for poor people and because we went to
college we could finally get a job and
move our mama out of sharecropping I
could move up in the company and Here I
am today he said so that when we talked
about the civil rights movement and dr.
King it's wonderful that it helped
blacks it's wonderful that it helped
women but what America needs to
understand is the country was changed
because it helped families of all races
men and women so I asked you to give the
civil rights movement a round of
applause please
now here's my question here's my
question what percent of Americans do
you think had earned a college degree in
the mid sixties what would you think
25-year Americans are known what percent
do you think then don't let me leave
Carnegie Mellon saying you're a risk
adverse either I hurt 10 for the simple
somebody anybody else 35 in very old 25
it was actually 10% 10% all right what
percent of whites we at that time we
broke things down the white and black we
had a native guide into the gradations
white and blacks what we said in the 60s
okay remember the Higher Education Act
the Civil Rights Act in 64 right the
building Rights Act in 65 the Higher
Education Act of 65 saying more
Americans go to college and this is what
so what percent of whites had a college
degree 2012 anybody else it was 11
percent 4 percent of blacks to 2 to 3
okay today what percent of Americans
have a college degree
I heard 30 things I might I heard 50
from added anybody else 25 anybody else
40 it's high it's it's just gotten to 30
percent 30 percent 4 percent of whites
33 anybody else it's not quite 40 30
percent what was said of blacks it's
about 18 percent and not quite 19 and
what's the fastest growing group in our
in our country and what percent of
Hispanics is actually about 15 percent
at this point all right what percent of
Asian Americans now I usually get a 90
from somebody that come on you know you
want to say you all really are risk
adverse mr. pres you got a risk adverse
student body out there and Sahara there
you know what you all are usually being
safe to get that a I got that
right you want to know before you said
get out the other limb I got that but it
is 55% of asian-americans many of like
my students most of my almost 30% of
Asian descent and the kids are the sons
and daughters they are Americans that's
that their parents came into grad school
and remained and now work at the
National Institutes of Health or NSA or
whatever but that is that the most the
best educated group in our country and
what a Native Americans what would you
think well below 14 percent just a
travesty okay now why do I tell you all
that you put it all together this is
what I'm saying that surprises most
educated Americans literally two-thirds
of Americans over 25 do not have college
degrees think about it think about well
over well over 60% of white Americans
and about 80% of blacks and 85% of
Hispanics don't have college degrees now
the first reaction from most of my
friends white/black whatever the race is
Freeman that couldn't be true everybody
I know has a college degree duh right
you know lawyers around lawyers math
professors around math with computer
scientists over on computer scientists
and plumbers who make more money than
any of you all or we're on plumbers all
right yeah and the fact is that but what
we don't so we don't know about other
people
and yet here's the challenge in the 60s
one didn't need a college degree to move
ahead today more than ever we need two
and four-year degrees and beyond masters
and PhDs so we have all these people who
are not able to take advantage of more
and more opportunities that are there
and in my area what we talk about is the
fact that we now have over 100 companies
on campus biotech and IT companies side
of our faculty about some Hopkins
faculty and other and we're producing
thousands of jobs so the idea of stem is
what's so wonderful is the idea of being
able to produce companies and jobs and
then they have people who can fill those
jobs who can help build the economy as
norm Augustine says the former head of
Lockheed Martin that the GDP in America
is somewhere between 50 and 70 percent
connected to the strength of of still
now I had the privilege of chairing the
National Academies Committee
under-representation in science and and
a part of that comes because we become
the leading producer among predominately
white schools and not in general blacks
would get these empty PhDs and I really
want to give Jim I never have a chance
to give Jim greenberg credit we had a we
had never thought I'd do this in the
yeah we had a break grant and funding
from a private person and Jim kept
talking about NSF money that was
available in iself money of it and and I
hadn't got a chance to get down in it
and he came in and almost cursed me out
get your butt down there and get some of
that money it was it was really great
and it did lead to much more federal
funding so would you give Jim greenberg
a hand for me I really I really
appreciate that great there because it
did that I'd get a public and private
funding together NSF and Bob Meyerhoff
was an MIT graduate and then other
national agencies understanding the
issue and this is what both super and
Farnam have been talking about when they
were at NSF and that's so powerful it is
that the most enlightened institutions
in our country understand well that we
must be producing students of all races
men and women in the STEM disciplines
and and beyond if we ought to be as
competitive as we want to be let me just
give you one final example um how many
of you in the room were between the ages
of 35 and 7-ish raise your hands
good I've got good news and bad news
which one you want first bad news is you
get no get over it it's okay I'm with
you so it's okay I'm over 60 but the
good news is you're the best educated in
the world it's second best in the world
only in Norway as a country it's
slightly better educated very
significant how many of you between 25
and 34 oh now you see the prize would
you raise your hands like I'm not in
that old group I'm Y all right I've got
good news and bad which one you want
first bad well the bad news is you're
not as smart as we are I hate to tell ya
they kidding
almost but kind of kidding but the fact
is you number 12 in the world as an
American generation you are literally
and what it is is that large numbers of
countries have had more success than we
have in
educating a larger percentages of the of
their population and it's not that we've
gone backwards we're just not moving
forward and a lot of it has to do with
bottom groups groups that are
academically that even though more
students are going to college they're
not graduating half of Americans almost
half who started never graduate we have
over 15 million Americans who started
college and never graduated and you know
when when I looked at the top and I like
the idea of MLK in the American
University the fact is the American
University has been the pathway to the
middle class so many of you how many of
you in the room are first-generation
college of person your families to go to
college either one I mean even our
Connie Kim Ellen look at this it's a
wonderful story and it's a story I would
argue that you should tell because
people need to know you can be the very
best and be the first to go to college
and and what has happened as a result of
that is the first person goes and people
watch to see what's going to happen and
all of a sudden that person does well
and is able to get a job and move out of
the parents home and bring others along
and families have moved of all races
have moved to the middle class because
of the first person who went to college
and that most of those people happen
sometime in the 60s there was a small
group before that very wealthy people
more white men than anybody before that
but what really started it quite frankly
was the the veterans act if you remember
the GI Bill in the 40s I was it was
Roosevelt who was powerful and with the
Social Security Act in 35 and in 44 the
GI Bill
what group fought the notion of funding
for veterans to go to college there was
one group that was more powerful than
any other who said if you allow those
veterans into universities and colleges
the institutions will become academic
hobo jungles
that's a quote university presidents
university presidents they really they
fought it they lobby totally get and
from Harvard to the University of
Chicago wonderfully educated people very
decent guys and I bring that up not to
be disparaging but for this reason even
the best educated in the world can be
limited in thought insight you get my
point
because when we are in power we are
comfortable with the way things are it
is only when we feel some discomfort or
appreciate the fact that the world needs
to change that we actually see the
changes and that's a part of what we've
done at my university fact is that years
ago we we had never seen a minority in
ane science course unless the kid had
been educated in a French system or a
British system in another country and
until maybe a decade ago we didn't even
realize only 12% of our faculty in
science and engineering who were tenured
or tenure-track were women and so I I
was very privileged to be the head of
our advanced program which is a
fundamentally transformational program
but we've gone from 12% women in science
and engineering on the faculty and
tenure engineers requisitions to almost
39% get my campus a hand for that it's a
big deal and so while we're talking
about the notion of improving or
increasing the numbers of minorities
performing in science or women in the
Faculty of science and engineering and
especially with technology and the
challenges there and congratulations to
you on what you've been able to achieve
in terms of 40 percent of your freshman
class in computer science being women
there are several fundamental guiding
principles one is the need to look in
the mirror itself with honesty the need
to rely on the data something you
appreciate to use analytics the need to
listen to the voices of the people from
the particular groups and there's a
piece that my colleagues and I wrote on
a theory of change and it speaks to this
notion of of developing empowering
settings we want our students to feel
empowered we want faculty to feel
empowered to speak the truth as they see
it I've really enjoyed being with your
administrators a day with the president
with the students and listening to their
voices I was very impressed because they
could talk about the wonderful things
that kind of get member and then they
can even speak to some of the honest
challenges that they face the fact
is when I chaired that committee that I
said on under-representation it didn't
surprise people that only 20% of blacks
and Hispanics who were succeeding who
were starting in math and science and
engineering were graduating in those
disciplines but but people were shocked
to learn only 32% of whites who began
with a major in those areas will remain
and only 41% of asian-americans and and
so the question becomes what is a
challenge well what our committee did it
was a little different was we didn't
simply point the finger at K to 12
you know universities blame high schools
who blame middle schools who blame
elementary schools who blame the family
right and then the father blames the
mother side of the family
it's like a finger pointing thing all
the way down the line and we said let's
stop the finger-pointing
let's focus on the issues and what we've
learned from my heart what we learn from
this program for minorities in science
and not others but we learned from the
women in science programs and the
seawood program Center for women 90 is
once we get the data once we analyze
things once we see what's working and
not let's not point fingers let's create
an environment of trust so we can
analyze the issues and support faculty
support students with the vision of
having greater representation of all
groups and let's not think that because
most students don't make it it simply
means we have high standards because the
question should be yes do you have high
standards when thinking about the rigor
but do you also have high standards when
thinking about the support to help
students come up to that rigor I would
argue that we have a moral
responsibility in the Academy if we
admit students and tell them they have a
chance of making it an engineering if
they work really hard the question is
are we doing all we can as an
institution to rethink the approach and
to understand how we can be even more
effective because innovation really
should mean looking in the mirror and
and believing that we can do things
differently and that we can expect
higher more from each group if we give
each group the support necessary and so
for us beginning with those students in
those
years twenty-five years ago it was
suggesting that we wanted not just to
help students make it through the
institution but rather we wanted to do
something that was bold we wanted to
produce a program that would have more
students excelling from every race than
ever before excelling at the level that
they'd want to go and get PhDs in the
work and if they were interested in
medicine not just an MD to clinical but
that they had the gravitas to think
about an MD PhD and so what has been
amazing is to see our students going on
to Harvard and Stanford to get these MD
PhDs or to become the first this and
first that at Michigan to other kinds of
places in computer science and to see
these students empowered to believe they
can change the world of all the things I
learned during the civil rights movement
developing a sense of self and being
taught to believe in self and to
understand that I could not afford to
allow anyone else to define who I am
those things were more important than
any others and what we're talking about
success in stem or strengthen humanities
or social sciences the real question for
the American University is how do we
reach out to students who are different
whether they are students with
disabilities students from low-income
backgrounds students from different
kinds of socio-economic situations all
kinds of differences how do we create a
culture in the spirit and dream of dr.
King that welcomes those students
embraces their differences expects the
most both from them and from ourselves
you know I'll never forget when we had
the first student earn an A in an
upper-level science course before our
math program I'm gonna stop because I
wanted to have questions before our my
off program we had never seen a black
earn an A in any of
science course now I go to many
universities unless that black had been
educated in another country but if the
kid was from Baltimore of New York just
hadn't happened that in the quantitative
area I'll never forget when we finally
got an A in genetics which was really
sensitive and we were having pizza and I
came in and all the kids were there this
was 20-some years ago and I said we in
genetics and all the guys from the
science and tech schools just knew they
had gotten a they've getting ready to
get up and take their bow and I called
the name of a young woman from a little
country school snow hill elephant and
Snow Hill Maryland right and when I
called her name she gasped and she
started crying and all of a sudden I
looked around and all these kids were
applauding got to their feet standing
ovations it was like a basketball game
it was it was incredible the women were
crying because they feel so good for the
guys were crying because they hadn't
gotten it you know for the wrong pride
all right they were all crying all right
make me cry but what was so amazing
about it was they were looking at this
young woman and thinking my god you can
get an A in genetics and look like her
he can be black you can be a woman and
it was a transformational moment it was
like breaking a barrier because since
that time we've had a z' in courses from
analytical chemistry you name the course
data structures all kinds of courses and
some of those kids now on the faculties
of Duke and Harvard and Stanford it is
the dream in one's hands being able to
believe it's possible I want you to
think about this fact Carnegie Mellon
you're one of the most prestigious
places in the world you produce some of
the best leaders in the world I think
you have an enormous chance an enormous
chance an opportunity to take your brand
and your goodwill and your brainpower
and your wonderful emphasis on science
of learning
and use it to figure out one of the
hardest problems that Dubois talked
about at the turn of the century this
challenge of race and poverty and
excellence you can become a leader in
the world in producing students from
these underrepresented groups who will
then transform the world kind of game
Ellen I challenge you to watch your
thoughts they become your words watch
your words they become your actions
watch your actions they become your
habits watch your habits they become
your character I tell my students your
character has everything to do with who
you are not only when people can see you
but what will you do when you don't
think anybody's watching so thoughts
will come words words become actions
actions become habits habits become
character watch your character it
becomes your destiny dreams and values
Carnegie Mellon you are so special and
you can be even better thank you all
very much
can I take a question thank you so much
I'm Richard shyness I'm the Dean of the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences and one of the leaders
of the Simon initiative it's a great
honor to be up here even just moderating
questions so we'll take about 20 minutes
of questions there are people on each
side of the aisle that have microphones
so if I call on you please wait for the
mic to arrive stand up give us a brief
idea of who you are and then ask your
question so I'll just ask the first
brief question can you come back next
week questions and I will say that I
said to the president and the final men
and the super that I really am looking
forward to building on some of the
initiatives we've had with you already I
really am honored to be here and look
forward to building that partnership the
same way we did it in itself and I have
a mentee in the room somewhere and
before she leaves she must because I
tried to recruit the UMBC but she came
here instead her name is Sam Lind and
she's got to be here somewhere
and whenever she is so when this is over
you'll get her mother's a VP or my cab
let's give her a hand with that Sam
right there and I the reason I tell you
this is she's having a great experience
I've heard that so I've been learning
through her I through her mother about
this place all right so make sure you
seen the evidence okay
all right thank you so much for your
talk you talked to us several times
about the Meyerhoff program I wonder if
you could tell us a bit more but I'd be
delighted to and I'm gonna tell you that
I want you to when you get a chance
going there's a 60 minutes piece written
they followed me and colleagues around
for 11 months for 15 minutes segment can
you imagine and it was like really
answering questions of the dissertation
everything we we claimed they made us
prove to them right how do you know that
it was wonderful but it is a program
designed first for it was started for
African Americans and actually for black
males because we're at the bottom of any
group and then we moved to women the
next year and the only reason we had
only men was because the guy who started
the program had just funded a program at
Goucher for women and he wanted to do
this for males and and when I said no we
want women in the program he said well
it's my ball and as
right but it was good that we did it
because it gave us a chance to think
about those issues and the purpose was
to help more kids succeed in science and
engineering and we decided to use the
the notion of Jim Collins about being
bold and hairy and our goal setting not
simply to help kids get through but
rather to help students excel to be so
good that they wouldn't want to go on to
grad school and get PhDs and become
professors and researchers and we
started small with 19 kids and every
year we only had money for 20-25 kids or
so and after a few years there was a
study looking at the number of
biochemistry majors in the country and
that particular year that was 67 black
bachelor's recipients in biochemistry 22
came from UMBC a third in the nation and
they all went on to grad school and in
some cases med school we but we have
emphasized the PhD as being the more
really the work that we need we need
physicians but we need people who going
to study the problems and so we one of
our how do you our Hardys investigator
rather Mike summers in biochemistry has
been one of the leading supporters of
that program and probably produces more
blacks and men and women will go on to
get PhDs in science including sending
people on to the faculty at Harvard or
in Franklin but he gives a talk to the
parents of high achieving minority kids
black and Hispanic now about health
disparities and how proportionately
higher are you gonna have in diabetes
and high blood pressure in all these
diseases quite frankly where you've got
more many more proportionately women and
people of color who are not succeeding
health-wise and his question is this if
you don't have scientists from those
populations studying those diseases
who's gonna do it
so the Meyerhoff is about producing
people who become leaders in research
whether in computer science or in
biochemistry and it's worked so well
that now at least a third of the program
will be white students who want that
same model well the model has worked so
well at UMBC a building community of
faculty
supporting the research of getting
students involved in the research very
early in their freshman year and of
talking about grad school from the
beginning and of solving problems real
problems on our campus at Hopkins and at
the Maryland Medical School those all
three that we have now used that model
to transform what we do throughout the
campus not just in science but in
scholars programs across other
disciplines and but the my office works
so well that right now both Chapel Hill
and Penn State are replicating the
program with big grant from the Howard
Hughes that program has been going for
about 20 to 23 years now
89 how do how does UMBC stack up in
terms of whatever right yes yes right
better than winner but I'll be glad to
tell you Jeff Jim and I fought all the
time by the way you should know this
overhead so it's really it's but he's
excellent the as I said I chaired the
committee or under representation so
there's a list for top 25 institutions
in producing blocks who going to get
PhDs in stem and one for Hispanics so
let me just go and so our strength has
been with the african-american
population in terms of minorities and
with students in general and a lot of
Asian American students we are now
increasing the numbers of Hispanics but
in terms of blacks
we're the only predominantly white
University in the top ten in producing
blacks who get PhDs everybody else is in
the top ten is an HBCU still you see MIT
is on that top 25 list though we're
about number six but that was up to 12
with the new data we actually would be
number one we're ahead of everybody in
MD PhDs for sure already in the life
sciences we're number one we're in the
top ten in technology areas in
engineering MIT is there NC State is
there
College Park is only there in the social
sciences
they have not done it in the sciences
and my alma mater is there in the life
sciences Illinois my graduate alma mater
we've worked with them from some of unit
Nancy Cantor and I worked well together
for years on the advanced program other
things but they've done well and they're
the only other program the white
University urbana-champaign go figure
right I'm really proud of them they
really have made a commitment to that
and what I said to your president and to
Farnum and others is that I'd like to
see kind of get melon on the list for
african-americans on the list for expand
if you get let me just say this if you
are producing five or six blacks a year
we're going to get PhDs you'd be in the
top 25 you should I mean that's a that's
a that's a step you've got all these
smart kids here how do we help them to
get to do well enough and if you're good
enough about it you want to go and get
you know because once you get the first
group and you can say you in the top 25
you can recruit so many more who will
want to come it's getting that first
level of success and that's that's what
they're so know at this point we we lead
the country so this is why so many
people are coming to look at the model
we've developed
oh I had called on her well somebody's
getting the mic let me just give you one
of the example if you get a chance look
at our look at our choice program which
is not in stem but when we talk about
MLK and the American University the
question is what are we doing for those
who at the bottom the least we put the
same amount of time we've had Meyerhoff
since 89 we've had the choice program
for children who are first-time
offenders and this is a program to keep
kids from going to jail kids between 8
and 15 years old these are kids of all
races heavily minority but not all a lot
of poor white kids mainly boys and we
supervise them 24 hours a day seven days
a week we made sure they up in the
morning in school during the day we
bring them on campus in the evenings we
totally we mentor we take them home we
make sure they stay at home at night why
the mother is not there usually she's
working or in other cases she's on drugs
so my middle class campus right there at
the airport is really working with
students of all races are working with
these children to keep them safe and
until last year we had never lost a kid
last year we had five kids killed one of
my best little boys 14 years old was in
his bed asleep they came in put the gun
here and just killed him because his
father had testify in the case why is it
important for a middle class place of
four places to know because this is a
part of America's issues you get them
it's not just other countries and while
we need to deal with issues involving
police justice and all of that 90 plus
percent of black children Hispanic
children boys who are killed or killed
by each other and we've not talked about
those issues we need to deal with
justice issues here but we have to deal
with the fundamental challenges in our
communities and I'm saying years from
now and people look back at the American
University I think I said where were you
when all these problems are going on
with all this brain power where were you
so we're we're out there in there
getting our hands immersed in that stuff
because it is where children go through
somebody else I'm capable I'm a freshman
here at CMU and I wanted to first of all
thank you so much for your talk and I
want to ask you you know if you saw the
State of the Union with President Obama
talking about you know his idea with
Community College being free for two yes
I want to know what your thoughts are on
that because the cost of college is of
course so high and increases every year
so I would imagine that if you go into
an impoverished community and you you
know say I'd like to you know inspire
your children to go to college in the
classroom so high would it not be a
better intermediate step to instead
proposed Community College or something
kind of a step below working up there
it's a very good question I if you look
are at the White House webpage of
whatever I was was actually there at the
White House giving a talk with the
Governor of Tennessee in the last month
the president's idea comes from what
Tennessee has been able to do the
governor who's Republican has actually
implemented such a program so that
children young people can have free the
costs covered for tuition and it does
have a lot of merit really does you may
not know this but almost half of
Americans starting Community College's
almost half and a number of faculty
members would have started off into your
institution so one can get a solid
education I always say this and you'll
appreciate my saying is the quality of
the education somebody gets it is less
connected to how much it cost and more
connected to how much one puts into it
you see you know if you looked at your
grad students if people come from public
institutions or whatever they've had to
you if you put just I have had many many
friends kids who've gone to very
expensive places who were just there
right and they got that gentleman or
lady C right you know so I don't care if
they paid a quarter million dollars for
education they didn't get much because
they didn't put much into it so it
depends on where you got the spear to
the kitchen I'm just saying make sure
you put all into it now here's my point
I want you to think about this the
challenge is how do we get enough
political support to make it happen at
the very least what I think will happen
is the conversation has begun that every
American student should have the
opportunity to get post-secondary
education and that is the fact now
a traditional four-year liberal arts
experience is not for everyone at the
same time Minister I mean boys don't go
to college at the same rate as girls did
you know that a minute race a lot of
boys aboard just as we got to work on
girls and technology areas we're down
there like 45% of American college
students being male all right and so we
need ways of supporting people in
different kinds of education in
community colleges from the traditional
going to four-year as well as other
kinds of post-secondary opportunities
there are a lot of great programs funded
by NSF involving biotech for two-year
kinds of programs that people don't know
about but community college to be able
to get that education is exactly what we
need we've really do it's very important
that we give people otherwise how they
gonna make a living that's the port and
pay taxes okay your speech highlighted
to me is a fundamental similarity
between learning and change making
change and that is that it's really what
we believe is possible in both of these
that makes the difference so you've been
so successful at your college what do
you think you can do that we could learn
from about changing belief yeah it's a
it's such a great question and we talked
before by Carol Dweck
and I work at Stanford about mind set
first of all we in America tend just say
to kids without even realizing either
you're good in math and science so
you're not you know and I'll ask this
this is it this is a really
sophisticated group you really are I
have to ask you to I ask every American
audience this question how many of you
knew by the time you in the 11th grade
that you either math science type or you
are history English in art so tight let
me see your hands
it's amazing even this kind of group now
but you all because you did so well you
probably I'm a math science like because
you do well but most people will say
that and then the next thing they'll say
is what I well I said well why didn't
you go into math and science well I was
just much better than the other area but
we as teachers even we have a way
thinking about K through 12 of giving a
look at a kid
if the student is really excited about
the work like I was that little nerdy
fat kid and loving the math problem so
he was oh come on for him but if you
like I don't know you're gonna say what
I'll help you this year but don't come
back next year you know that message is
sent all the time with our people that
way the body language people know when
you when a teacher doesn't think they
really have it I was thinking at a
wonderful girl school in Nashville a
very wealthy school ok and I was working
with these little girls on a math
problem and the teacher was fabulous
teacher except she came to me she said
they're not mad people
these kids were 13 years old she'd
already decided don't spend too much
time with them 110 I'm at fever now this
is that one of the finest places it
happens all the time we've got to change
the attitudes of people about that
because we need more people not because
they gotta become a big time super Oh
fun I'm gonna be right you know is but
rather they kick they can be literate
citizens in science even you see we need
more of that let me just say this to the
professorial here if most students are
weeded out of science they don't feel
good about science and engineering why
would we expect the public even the
educated public to want to support basic
research at NSF or NIH if they didn't
have a good experience themselves if
even our best educated people did not
have a good experience I cannot tell you
when I asked the question how many of
you started with a major in science and
engineering and changing majors people
kind of guiltily raised their hands very
successful people CEOs all the time so
why would we expect so I'm saying if for
no other reason is self-interest we need
creative ways of having people have a
great experience they don't have to
major in it but I mean to have good
experiences in the coursework that they
take but and kind of your mentor has
done a lot to help with that but we
still all have a lot of work to do
right sure and it's a great question
that it goes to what we're doing with
Chapel Hill and Penn State and faculty
working with faculty this notion of
building community among students and
helping students of all races to work
together in groups and getting away from
the competitive curve system which which
tends to discourage people from helping
each other but so much and creating an
environment which people say how they're
really doing the typical response from a
student who even has gotten to D is I'm
okay because students don't want to it's
human nature you don't want to tell
people I'm not doing well and so it's
how do you create a culture of which you
can have the kind of safe environment
that T is here somewhere I'm hoping of
the mouth wasn't it take what my house
set up set up she's a fourth-year PhD in
mechanical engineering civilian I'm very
proud of the thing I'm very proud of her
and to the Carnegie Mellon's credit came
here as a high school kid from Maryland
and had a good experience I'm very proud
of it and I'd bring it up because she
knows how we have the cohort experiences
so people and I ask questions okay
who feels really good about performance
in the last whatever but then we say
okay who bombed who didn't do well and
to have an environment people say this
is really not going well and then they
have students who did do well get
together with them
I mean creating that culture where
people learn to get to say what they
need help with early and then others who
say let me work with you and make sure
you can make it makes a difference and
for us every group is somewhat
responsible for the group right below it
so the first in the first mile house
everybody we'll call em ones I didn't
like that I said it was a gun okay that
was that male group of course right I
said you know why don't you call
yourself ms once my house scallops one
they said that's a disease we'd rather
be a gun that a disease
so they won out all right then they got
the m16 all right now they had liked em
34 but every group it wants to give em
two suits of Kevin threes all the way
you and what I'm 18 you see what I'm
saying so every cohort now we do the
same thing with the setup of women and
IT they have courts and in every one of
our programs across the campus people
are responsible for some people who are
younger and there's the point I'm making
having a sense of responsibility for
people beyond oneself is a part of it I
think of a dream of what we in America
should be thinking about because the key
is this you're gonna be the leaders in
the world and if you've only learned how
to take care of self what happens to
everybody else and so the message that I
leave you with is this that as a student
you want the opportunity yes to excel to
understand how important hard work is
how important it is to ask the questions
how important it is to connect with
people and to know your faculty well and
to dream big about what you can do in
the world and you want the opportunity
to look at people who are not doing as
well you've got a lot of freshmen right
now who are feeling very ordinary at any
my University in yours there are kids
who did not do well who got AIDS in high
school and they got C's or DS he already
having to repeat ku I think you call it
an R is that right
see I'm learning about your are today -
uh-huh yeah and and they're feeling bad
about it and they don't want to tell
anybody and I'm saying that what part of
what is needed is this creating a
culture in which you take ownership of
somebody else to give them that support
it makes all the difference in the world
I leave you with the notion that any
progress really require struggle some of
you heard me say they did my wife and I
studying friends since high school we
haven't done it but we do it in there as
a kind of gift to ourselves and it's
romantic
right so my family my loser to do from
say pasca New Zealand Pauline let's say
poor for no sir I never said the
Mirage and I'm one of the points I've
just learned is by
paulownia and one of the lines says
legend it is your play the pan the joy
comes only after the struggle I
challenge you kind of get melon to
struggle with the issues you can achieve
anything because you're just that good
thank you all